asks for Lensky searched for desmond
excises are coming and new peniston is afraid of
gays and our task is
eyewitnesses van buren
aristova is less than 10 young and a
flock from east end kiev
and let a snack in the office in
sauce riveted insider chicory from here for
years from a leaf
on the shore up x3 n UAH russia by the Dutch
lookin' for women's of address duplicates
get adobe bridge at any moment malia jones
file takamine dudes interval from
axis here's their wars january day file
worry vikings using
beijing bahia bag in the hands of life in
still caught want a hangout model
lobbyists by reprimand fine barn  the site
of the
Soros Foundation Kirkhi soldier or does not like this
industry and ramil tyson's tooth set
people have been here
with victorious wrath and
in the delicacy sobinka yellow yesterday all
the media in the west
exploded with videos from
Kremenchug where they
showed footage of a burning shopping
center accusing the Russian military of  the fact
that they are bombing civilian
infrastructure the Russian Ministry of
Defense  and very clearly and clearly explained
what actually happened bombed the
hangar where the American
European weapons and ammunition arrived and as
a result of
[music]
concreting we
don’t bother you here no and
as a result where the tinting of the ammunition
caught fire standing next to empty
shopping centers
at the same time by the husband of sent to say  still
alive already there, at the
moment, we can say about the victim, like we
mean
c18 found bodies and this fragment of all the
remains and
21 especially the
United States is located well, and such is respected, it
still disappeared top she returned and
kind of whose friends I know my I would drag  knows
and disagrees with their people in liqueur 24
sold in the data in which the slave mayor only
dollars car I, as stupidly knowing, you
hurt turned around 59 hoarse people burned
and the woman was ragged in blood completely
there so like a girl to with cellars and
raised and you pulled the contribution  this girl
gave us consciousness, she lost consciousness,
but after a healthy one for years,
glass fell into the house  e and I, with a child
in my arms in downy in eleonas, a
wave hit my name, we fell, it’s not a
secret, the leg was knocked down here, we fell together, threw us
back to the table, lunch, we color, I
come to the cemetery, lunch, and now it
all started, all a few lodygins in the
hands of pisek well you  would like to grab
on hands hang / exit
I have a hot worries collided with it and
we fell on the pavement itching and that's it
and everyone ran in the race still maybe
what did you belle
belle alarm for filming your children and in the
Yankee and my dream of the day is being shelled by
Russian  rockets from belgorod ritual
i my children and we arrived three and three days ago
and skoda
instead of kremenchug i thought there
would be magnets for you 5 she i prayed and i
yesterday butt showed us all of us in
ukraine by her husband they demand them you get the
prices on the soul of laka  ya and today I came
with you girls to we
still play
who it is because of strangling them who today who
yesterday for clay
named soul skoda it
all happened and
learn another dish yaki were a clerk
until yesterday ter  an act with my father, I directly and a
terrorist attack and genocide of the Ukrainian people,
which I didn’t get what I deserved